how's the gum resumes Peter pack welcome
back to alien isolation part 2 are you
excited because I am let's continue this
we crash-landed I guess you could call
it on this giant space station the
Isidora and we're about to enter I think
all our friends are dead find help I
think we're gonna find him help here
unless aliens like plot twist aliens
love you the aliens actually wants to
help you but you and the aliens just
hang out and have a great time the end
save station user decision minds of
anything all right same station thank
you thank you very much cool very cool
very chic well hello some scrap I'll
take it thank you very much the hell are
we going this way
hello I just crashed landed where's my
nevermind back
I think this place is falling apart and
Oh interesting
primary airlock okay nevermind orbital
space stabilizer oh that doesn't look
good space plus fire equals bad got it
all right what do we got here about tall
hello
let's go through very nice very chic
it's kind of cozy Oh
I don't think we should stay here for
too long what did we have like 24 hours
to get back to safety yeah yeah I think
we're fine it is beautiful thank you
okay
[Music]
employers lunch access terminal zavasta
link my favorite OS ever decommissioning
so boys and girls
you probably heard the whispers about
Sevastopol by now and I can confirm it's
vegetable Sevastopol is being
decommissioned I will go over with each
of you what this means in regards to
your contracts and next placement but
for now we still have a job to do
the suits once is done with a skeleton
crew which means we'll only be getting a
few outside contractors to help but it
does mean overtime I recommend taking
what you can while it's available you
should point out I should point out that
the DES Commission does not mean lucky
dip everything here has to be accounted
for and I will personally escort anyone
found helping themselves to equipment to
marshal weights chief marshal weights
will have like space cops and stuff
that's awesome I want to be a space cop
that's like my dream is now right
Oh nice little bridge how convenient
oh god no please no oh [ __ ] oh hell no
it's over
we're dead now there's an alien behind
me isn't it Pecha no we're actually fine
oh my fly
okay this'll help it's will help hi
boots
how are you doing Manny good thanks play
whoa calm down flare sorry whoops I'm
gonna make sure I don't miss anything I
saw something
Oh are we going through like what is
this
like mortgage
now we can't be well what happened here
damn
I'm sure it's coughing a lot
you always know working Joe someone some
stranger's well get free shots go at it
keep moving
hotshot sorry oh hello keep moving
thanks bloody ball it's you're my new
mentor bloody wall that's my new thing
I'll just hang out with bloody wall Oh
lipstick nope it's a bonding agent of
course oh yeah what do we got we got
something some good music
hello this is my jam
my Space Jam shout out I'm sorry
let's get going Oh anyone here I don't
think so
what are you talking to she thought of
me I think this is the space station so
what is it that's awesome
it's freaking huge alright look at the
act
yes I don't know if Space Station has
beds but okay well I guess we keep going
don't kill me please
I come in peace I'm sweet and you think
your work
well her sassiness we're just gonna get
along just fine you and me Ripley
[Music]
all right I don't need your help I'm a
strong independent woman down the code
what shits over sooner three four zero
alright I remember that restore power
all right sounds good ah how nice
hey hey wait up
come on take me with you please I have
any friends
I talked to a flare I'm desperate oh
come on are you serious
gosh darn it
well they got some loot got some more
loot here for it - that's like my lucky
number
it's not I lied I just wanted to be cool
Oh what was the count
no yes I know it's nothing impressive at
all but I'm like for me and it is cuz
like I'm the worst with with numbers I
can't remember I used to study math -
that was this blueprint of a I'm a med
kit you found a blueprint he's cute for
crafting oh I can't craft it you know
can i I wanted to use the med kit I
don't really need a bag hmm hey free
drugs come on don't hate if you were
alone in the Space Station you get funky
- don't do drugs unless there's an alien
and stuff that's all I'm gonna say this
is pretty [ __ ] cool so far I really
like it it's so I'd miss Merrik I really
feel like I'm in the game
do you breasts feel it
no that's you have to pee okay
Oh God
I don't think this place likes me
I think it's trying to purge me by
twerking what do we got now can we now
make it no I just collect a bunch of
lipsticks and stuff but all for nothing
I would say don't kill me I know karate
what the hell happened here whoa look at
that that's so cool
that's [ __ ] cool gift shop baggage
good we are at a fly Airport that's cool
they all got canceled huh interesting
destination Barnard's star i want to go
there Ross 1:5 for that sounds amazing
I'm gonna call my mom about this now
[ __ ] she does have Skype or video comm
Pro key line amazing Sebastopol no wait
it's our flight call Isidora or is this
the company called Sebastopol I think
the company is domestic I think I'm
working for Celeste what does this can
be useless now
whoa whoa what is that oh yeah the
tories is our chef help come on
I don't need come on dammit why you're
closed ate well
yeah darlin Oh God
sorry garbage sorry
well we're dead
I like how it's starting off very subtle
- very creepy I like it do you like it -
garbage
exactly where's this restored power
don't tell me what to do door I'll call
my mom on you if she used vidicon cred
up amusements sounds nice
I would love some mu there we go that's
our amusement
that [ __ ] flare high points I shut
down will ya
no matter my desert are we doing
anything here how many times there we go
very good points what is this you run
around Rex come on I wanted to play this
is Mike no I love it's like future with
like spaceship and all that but the the
computers are just terrible they're like
from the 80s it's awesome how does that
work oh oh [ __ ] no oh oh hell no now
what do you do okay all right Claire you
go in there and check if it's safe
is it safe okay what was that
hello Chinese restaurant that Chinese
maybe Japanese save station cha save yes
please thank you I like you you're my
new friend Oh computer subasta link my
favorite OS I'm gonna say that every
time no I'm not I don't know what my dog
wants I'm sorry Zoe
I'm sorry but I won't need you to come
in next week as you know the show has
been in trouble for some time now and I
couldn't hold off the creditor curlers
any luck can't say that warrant credit
energy there's just no one coming to the
Sebastopol anymore it's it's not just us
either it sounds like the whole station
is in the red and they're pulling the
plug going to sell it off for scrap I
guess I would speak to one of the
engineers and he reckons it all else is
soon I'm telling you this so you can
stick around so you don't stick around
and look for another job so I was
supposed to finish time to move on
Harper so what happened why is that bro
well I guess we know what happened
what is Apollo Apollo is the central AI
that monitors so whatever you are you
know you're in safe hands I don't know
what I feel about dad thank you okay
my dog's pissing me off alright
[Music]
not even the space cops are getting huh
well that's a little sad to hear it's
not really like it's my fault though I
just came here hello
oh [ __ ]
nope no god I wish I had my flare now I
got nothing hello it's only one way to
go huh only one way to go
she scattered to get to her head I love
if I can feel familiar in this place so
damn place is falling apart because
that's my house Lilly but because it's
an airport or whatever it's kind of
awesome
what are you are you're cute
a space vacuum you're quite adorable
aren't you what is your name there sir
let me see here Harold Harold is that
your name you look cute as a bee I don't
think that's how you say it excuse me
Harold I have to figure out how to get
help
well Harold it it would seem that I
would need your help can I go in here
yes oh I didn't mean to touch your bum
Harold I'll come back for you Harold
don't worry
I want
feel safe at all I thought as a matter
of fact quite unsafe
and dim all the sounds in this game are
amazing how people are listening to
headphones it's that it's not that guy
from jackass Oh Jade says what was that
what was that steve-o steve-o [ __ ] you
Steve oh god [ __ ] me man oh what's that
where they go in I know nobody's knowing
what is this place I want to go home I'm
gonna go home to my mom
I hear beeping that do anything open
please
what do we got here
do I need to turn you on why is the
power off everywhere surprise
I don't know so far away I'm really
bumped into anyone nice maintenance jack
interesting god damn it this place is
hot to Hajj for ma if you know what I
mean
you don't only need there to be honest
jesus [ __ ] christ man calm down I'm
walking on sunshine yeah yeah oh these
are dead bodies I'm walking ass
what am I supposed to go the game is
just like [ __ ] you keep going and stuff
I'm like it looks like we need a main
thing his Jack is in our right steve-o
[ __ ] the marshals looters will pay is
that a safe station alright save
stations
gotta love my save station
ah it's pretty it's pretty interesting
so far I really love the atmosphere I
hope you boys dig it as well I'm gonna
have to break and cut another episode
here if you enjoy watching brothers as
always thank you so much for leaving a
like and supporting this series I you
did amazing in the last one I really
appreciate it so thank you
that's all for me for now as always stay
awesome